here's what we're gonna do uh uh uh we
are going to get some beautiful pastrami
from i believe pastrami queen yeah look
at that look at that pastrami queen on
the upper last side yeah dump your
pastrami right there dump it in that big
bowl okay and now tommy's gonna get hot
right
nothing better than hot pastrami you
have a huge tattoo on my back that says
hot pastrami really like ben affleck and
uh it hurts a lot um okay so we got our
pastrami right and that's kind of
cooking a little bit with these onions
you know what's happening is that
marbleization sort of melting
right rendering so it's getting all
juicy all that fat is kind of cooking
the the onions and the pastrami right
here look at that
very important right here
this is
sauerkraut so what we're going to do is
we're going to dump that in there right
and the great thing is
this this sauerkraut it kind of keeps
everything nice and i don't want to say
what moist
moist just say it moist it's what it is
okay so everything here is getting nice
and
kind of hot so what do we have right
here oh some beautiful
nice mustard yellow mustard a little
mootarda right there that is really good
this is there is definitely a scent
coming up
you're basically making homemade mustard
gas for a minute wow
but it is so worth it so now what's the
most important part of stuffing
bread there we go look what we have
right here just some beautiful rye bread
okay
and this has been either left out or
toasted so it's not too soft you want to
have a little bit of
crunch to it right
dump in some bread i could we put this
in the oven so what we're going to do
before we touch the oven in the oven or
do we do it all in the dutch before we
do the dutch oven in the oven what we
want to do is we're going to take some
eggs right because the eggs
find it right here they're going to bind
it thank you i'm trying to bind it did
you use every egg this is so many eggs
well they wanted to make sure that we
had a lot in case but oh i think you
could normally use four to six this is
probably 30 or 40 yeah
and then just kind of mix it all
together so everything's got that like
goopy eggy
stuff on there and the bread and
everything is kind of touching
everything a little bit
and then this is where things get a
little nuts you guys
know what are you guys doing so wait
just to be clear this is where it gets
nuts this is where it gets nuts this is
where you you take it to the next level
okay all right
my favorite thing in the world
is cheese
this looks like i can tell you what this
is right now ready
that's a that's a that's a swiss that's
a nice swiss right there
you can tell that because there's a
giant thing of swiss there so that's
and then all you do
is you just cake it in cheese sprinkle
sprinkle give it a nice sprinkle god i'm
salivating look at that look at that's a
lot of cheese yeah look at it yeah
remember to call me the seagull when i
was a kid
because of this
here we go
look at that
that's friendship right there
that's friendship
so what we're going to do now we're
going to put this in the oven my god
this smells really good already okay let
me get the you can get the door for me
right here what a true sous chef does
and then i will put this one in here
okay and then i'm going to grab a this
this might be hot now right yeah so
here's what it looks like oh my gosh
ready for this
look at that
look at that
please watch this
i'm gonna get rid of this guy right here
here we go so this is
look at that oh my god my oh my sweet
lord look at that right there oh my god
ross
boom
oh the boss right here
right here oh my gosh i don't know what
makes you think i want any
[Laughter]
and i'm gonna have a little plate my
darn self
right here oh yeah you're missing some i
mean not that i even i don't know
okay ready enjoy the fruits of our labor
okay
[Applause]
we've discussed this before and ross if
you want in we're going to open a
restaurant called
stuffed
yeah and it's all kinds of stuff
i'm investing right i'm looking for
angel investors
it ain't just savories you get bread
pudding oh yeah yeah or any kind of
bread based
you know what's so good sticky toffee
pudding oh my god it's on the menu it's
on the menu we're looking for angel
investors reach out to me on my
instagram page dm
dm me and say i have your money that
would be great
i suggest you all enjoy
the new series the after party with an
extraordinary cast and ike who just you
shred so hard and we get on the ride
immediately at word go and you're just
my favorite and the show is no exception
the after party it's on apple tv plus
please watch it it is fantastic
[Music]
you